Hey guys, Pete here. today's Game of
Thrones Season eight bonus video will be
about an idea that I started seeing pop
up in my comments a little more than a
week ago the idea is that the Night King
won't be at the Battle of Winterfell at
all and then he has another target in
mind
I thought so many times that I knew it
was popular and it's one of those ideas
that people like so much that they speak
of it as fact personally I think that he
will be there and my initial thinking
about the idea was that it didn't make
sense based on what we've seen since I
kept hearing about it I thought I should
check out the theory and turns out it's
not a bad idea and that it addresses
some problems that I brought up in
previous videos myself mainly if the
White Walkers are defeated in Episode
three why is the second half of the
season the longer half they are the real
threat right it's a legitimate concern and
when I think most of us have been asking
when I asked it in the video six weeks
ago most people then were thinking that
the Dead would win at Winterfell the
heroes would escape and that would set
up a final showdown in episode 5 lately
the popular opinion has shifted based on
the theory that the Night King would
actually attack King's Landing while the
rest of his army is attacking Winterfell
I've been travelling this week so I
haven't been able to make a video for
the past couple of days and I've been
thinking about this the entire time I
wish I could say that I knew if it would
happen or not one way or the other but I
can't my gut tells me it won't so this
video will be about my thinking and how
I got to that point initially when I
heard this idea I didn't like it because
it didn't align with anything I had been
thinking might be motivations for the
night king I do expect there to be a big
twist related to the battle but in my
mind King's Landing wouldn't be where
the White Walkers would be looking if
you haven't read the theory I will put a
link to the original reddit post in the
description but the idea is that it
would be easy for Ray gall and drogue on
to take Viserion out in the battle
since he's a white and can be destroyed
by fire the Night King is not stupid so
he wouldn't put his new superweapon out
there at the Battle of Winterfell just
to lose it instead he would go to King's
Landing and create a new southern army
this would be a twist and I think there
is no question that the knight King is a
strategist but I run into more than a
few problems when I try to think this
through first the idea that Viserion is
a garden-variety wight I understand why
people think this I get it he was dead
before the night King turned him White
Walkers on the other hand aren't dead
they're living people who returned this
was a big debate in the aftermath of
season 7 and where I ended up is that it
isn't settled mainly because Viserion
isn't a human he's a magical entity and
I don't think we can assume rules about
his inherent vulnerabilities this is a
huge rabbit hole I don't want to go down
in this video there's good arguments on
both sides of it and I don't think we
can say for sure what Viserion is or
what can take him out of course if he is
a white this would be a big issue in a
battle where the living are going to be
using fire liberally but essentially I
don't think that means he would look for
another target because of this why not
just put Viserion somewhere safe nearby
while the battle is going on at hardhome
the night King seemed fine sitting back
and watching while the whites destroyed
the wildling why would he not approach
the Battle of Winterfell in the same way
I agree with the theory in that he's not
dumb but don't think this means his best
option is to take vissarion somewhere
else while he leaves the battle in the
hands of his underling the only
engagement we've seen south of the wall
is what happened at last hearth we
didn't actually see the attack but what
we saw of the yard looked like what you
might expect in that scenario it doesn't
appear that the night King arrived and
burned everything to the ground with his
dragon instead it looks like the
defenders were overrun by White's and
the bodies were raised and added to his
army so yes the night King does have a
dragon but he doesn't seem to be getting
all unnecessarily Burny with it my next
problem is that it doesn't seem to me
that going to burn everyone in King's
Landing with dragon fire equates to the
best way to build up your army I kind of
wonder how that would even work since
dragon fire is regarded as one of the
most destructive forces in the game of
thrones world Aegon the conquerer using
the black dreads fire to melt the stone
towers of Harrenhal as just one example
dragon fire melts stone
it's that hot it's lethal and it doesn't
seem there would be much left behind of
the dead to use as an army
I assume the idea is that he flies south
solo because that's the only way it
would work and making a new dead army
with dragon fire seems problematic even
if you don't agree with that there are
plenty of other places with people the
knight King could grow his army for
instance Sansa called the banners but we
know Lord Glover at Deepwood Motte
refused to come he could have flown this
Aryan over there killed everyone and
raised their ashes and then he couldn't
mount a surprise attack in the coming
battle also there's plenty of places
between the north and King's Landing
along the way so it just doesn't really
stand out to me as the most obvious
target if the night king was going
south to lay waste to Kings Landing
that might make more sense in it's a
place that has a high population density
but other than killing a lot of people
fast why would the night King be
interested in the city as viewers we're
interested in the city because it's
Westeros' seat of power
it's where the iron throne and the
current queen are but the White Walkers
aren't trying to rule Westeros they're
trying to exterminate its inhabitants to
this point there hasn't been much to
indicate there would be any reason why
hitting King's Landing with a surprise
attack would be better than slowly
destroying everyone on the way there and
arriving in the south with the super
army that could smash whoever might be
waiting for them now the theory points
out brands vision from season four where
he saw the shadow of a dragon over
King's Landing and the destroyed throne
room from Daenerys house of the undying
vision to support his idea this is
compelling since everything else in that
vision seems to have come to pass I
think it's interesting but not
conclusive I think one way or another no
matter what happens at Winterfell these
two things can still happen for me there
would need to be another reason the
night King saw King's Landing as a
priority to think he would turn his
attention away from the battle that's in
front of him so I'm not sure if we
should think of a Syrian as a highly
flammable liability but if he is I don't
think that the knight King needs to take
him elsewhere we've seen them be patient
and now that he is through the
all times on his side also I don't see
how he can add to his army with
Vissarion as a guy who can reanimate the
dead dragon fire seems like overkill
especially since his current plan seems
to be working fine there's no problems
he's just adding to his army as he goes
there's also new information since this
idea came out the theory of the night
King going to King's Landing emerged
before episode 2 aired during the
episode we had an explanation from bran
about what the night King once that went
like this bran he'll come from me he's
tried before many times with many
three-eyed Raven Sam why what does he
want an endless night an endless night
he wants to erase this world and I am
its memory this gives us the idea that
there is something specific in
Winterfell bran that the night king
views as a priority this seems to be in
line with his movements since he appears
to be headed straight there we know
since Norman and the boys went around
his army that besides that shortstop in
last hearth that's what they seem to be
doing if I didn't jump on the bandwagon
of him heading to King's Landing before
this came out this information doesn't
move me in that direction is what bran
saying here the whole story
probably not it may just be all he knows
right now or all of what he thought he
needed to say to get his plan in motion
still we've seen the night King come for
him
he was waiting to mark Bran the first
time he entered the weirwood net without
the three-eyed raven once he did that he
went straight to the three-eyed Ravens
cave and tried to kill him
he killed the old three-eyed Raven
himself and I have no doubts that he
would have killed Bryan at that point if
he could have on top of being the
world's memory bran is a threat he's the
last green sphere and the last
connection to the children of the forest
magic that we know about in the story
that's the magic that created the White
Walkers and it's the magic that keeps
them killing the only way I see the
night King turning away from that goal
is there is something specific in King's
Landing that gets him closer to killing
brand I think it's that important and
into this point I can't think of what
that might be before the show got so far
ahead of the books I always imagined the
Isle of faces and the way
would trees that are there would be part
of the night Kings endgame but I
basically lost hope that it'll come up
on the show if this theory was about him
going there to destroy the weirwoods
that would make sense to me but but the
show would have to do a lot of
explaining for people to understand what
was even going on if it did go there if
the show foreshadowed the Isle of faces
even a little bit I could possibly see
the night King swinging by King's
Landing to destroy it after the gods I
but I'm not holding my breath
I think even if he went to the Citadel's
and destroyed that like the collection
of works that are there that would be a
little bit confusing for some people if
the night King went there I think that
is basically King's Landing or nowhere
and I'm leaning towards nowhere so why
is this idea so popular like I said it's
a good idea there's questions that need
to be answered and it does answer them I
think part of it is that we just know
there will be of twist we want to know
what that twist is and King's Landing is
the only place left outside of
Winterfell that we know will definitely
be part of the story one way or another
Cersei will have to be dealt with so
does this mean that I think that the
night king will die in episode 3 no I
suppose he could but this really does
seem too early and that's another reason
why this idea has gotten so much
attention and to sum it all up I do
think there will be a twist but I don't
think it's going to be the night King
turning King's Landing into a new
southern army I could be wrong but I
think there are better options if he
wants to grow the size of his army and
other targets that would make more sense
I think that what brand said at the war
council is very important and that the
night King will be gunning for him I
don't know if the Battle of Winterfell
will be decisive one way or another or
if it will serve to set the table for
the final confrontation I do know that
I'm excited to watch it and I hope it'll
live up to the height I think it goes
without saying that there will be
another battle after the Battle of
Winterfell I think it also goes without
saying that Cersei will have to be
removed from her place of power before
all said and done but none of what we
know in that regard leads me to believe
that going to King's Landing is
necessary so I'm just leaning towards it
not
happening I think there's a lot of
really good set up and I don't think
that the night king would have to die at
Winterfell in order for that to be an
amazing episode of television let me
know what you guys think in the comments
though are you still thinking that going
to King's Landing makes the most sense
for the night King and Viserion if
that's the case will he not show up at
the Battle of Winterfell at all
well his second-in-command take the
opportunity to become a main character
and of course who do you think will die
after all those setups in Episode two
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
want to follow along for the rest of the
ride as mentioned I have been travelling
I had to travel so I haven't made as
many videos as I would like this week
but I will get back to my regular
schedule when I get back home next week
so thanks for watching and I'll talk to
you soon